Voy a empezar por lo más fácil,
la consulta popular está dividida.
Ahí está la cámara, verdad, ujum.
La consulta popular está dividida en
5 preguntas que buscan reformar la Constitución,
que son estas. De aquí, las del referéndum,
las del referéndum, ¿que son estas preguntas iniciales
y las siguientes 6?
Porque son 11,
las 5/1 de referéndum buscan modificar la Constitución
y las 6 siguientes
son preguntas de consulta popular.
Es decir, no buscan las de consulta popular
reformar la constitución,
sino que lo que buscan básicamente
es reformar el código orgánico
integral penal y la ley de extinción de dominio.
Primera cuestión.
Y ahí voy por un segundo tema
que igual es muy fácil de entender.
Sí, nuevamente
estas 6 preguntas de consulta popular,
la que ustedes tienen aquí,
la pregunta f. Sí,
la pregunta f
es una pregunta absolutamente ineficaz,
al punto que ni siquiera tiene anexo.
Vamos a leerla. Solo tiene. Consideran,
por supuesto, porfa,
léela ahí. Pregunta uno, casillero f.
Está usted de acuerdo con que las fuerzas
armadas realicen
control de armas,
municiones, explosivos y accesorios
permanentemente en las rutas,
caminos, vías
y corredores autorizados
para el ingreso a los centros de rehabilitación social.
Esto ya está vigente en la ley de seguridad pública.
Esto no es nada nuevo.
No hay ni siquiera anexos.
Exacto. Y fíjate,
aquí está el anexo de esta pregunta.
Ajá, revísale a ver.
Está solo los considerandos.
Yo sí, y no tiene.
Y no tiene anexos.
Claro, tienen los Considerandos okay, considerando es
los considerando son las motivaciones.
Las motivaciones únicamente son los justificativos
del por qué se plantea esa pregunta. Okay, okay
continuó, entonces, esto ya está,
esto ni siquiera tenía que haberse preguntado
exactamente, eso ya existe
y tenemos. A continuación
tenemos 2 4 5 preguntas
que se refieren en cambio a consulta popular
y estas preguntas
consulta popular.
En cambio, si tú les revisas,
yo invito que la gente las chequee
igual. Al reverso tenemos los anexos
y cada una de esas preguntas,
luego de los considerandos en el anexo,
siempre llegan a la siguiente conclusión,
revísales al hombre
que será necesario, ajá que el Presidente Novoa
envíe proyectos de ley a la asamblea
en el plazo de 5 días
desde que se aprueben estas preguntas
para que a su vez, para que a su vez
la asamblea los
en un plazo de 60 días dice, fíjate tú,
en caso de ser aprobada la presente pregunta,
el Presidente de la República
en el plazo
máximo de 5 días posteriores a la publicación
de los resultados,
remitirá el proyecto de ley
reformatoria al código orgánico
integral penal
que contenga las reformas
para cumplir lo establecido en esta pregunta,
la asamblea Nacional contará como el plazo
plazo máximo
de 60 días para debatir y aprobar la reforma legal,
conforme el trámite previsto en la ley de materia.
Esto está en la pregunta 4, en la pregunta 5
y en la pregunta 6, si no me equivoco, ¿verdad?
Claro, o sea Lo mismo que pudo haber hecho
sin necesidad de ir a consulta
lo está haciendo ahora.
Entonces eh, esto está en estas preguntas,
que básicamente es lo que tú me decías,
que era innecesario ponerla en una consulta popular,
exactamente ya. Okay, absolutamente innecesario,
porque si es que al final del día tú vas a terminar
enviando proyectos de ley a la asamblea Nacional,
¿significa que ya no quieres saltarte el procedimiento
parlamentario ordinario?
Pues sí, si, si,
si es que tú buscas enviar esas
esas iniciativas legislativas de la asamblea,
¿de qué te sirve?
¿Convocar a una consulta popular?
Es absolutamente ineficaz
porque, eh el sentido,
¿cuál es la perspectiva de una consulta popular?
Ajá, tú lo que buscas es
sobre todo evitarte el trámite parlamentario.
Tú lo que dices es,
no quiero que se vaya la asamblea
porque allá hay que discutir,
allá hay trabas políticas.
Tal vez no tenga los 70 votos
y como no voy a tener los 70 votos,
entonces directamente,
si es que el pueblo ecuatoriano me dice sí,
aprueba, el pueblo se publica en el registro oficial ya
y esto directamente
entró en vigencia.
Pero el momento que tú pones en los anexos
que en el plazo de 5 días
se va a enviar a la asamblea proyectos de ley,
tú incluso estás condicionando
el futuro de tu propia consulta popular,
porque lo que tú estás diciendo es
si es que tengo los votos,
entonces probablemente esto se llegará a cumplir.
Yo sé Que el cumplimiento,
valga la redundancia de una consulta popular
es de obligatorio
e inmediato cumplimiento, claro.
Pero también es verdad que quedamos
de expensas de la asamblea ujum,
es decir,
quién garantiza que existan los votos para esto,
acuérdate lo que pasó con la ley de comunicación,
se aprobó la constitución en el año 2 008
y una de las transitorias decía
que en el plazo de un año